[Música]
el intento de rusia de tomar que fue
parece haberse estancado las autoridades
ucranianas lograron retomar el control
del suburbio estratégico de macarí
mientras otras ciudades se resisten al
borde del desastre humanitario
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres le dijo a rusia que no podrá
ganar su guerra absurda en ucrania el
organismo advirtió del aumento de
refugiados y que la invasión puede
llevar a una crisis global de hambre
tenemos análisis
alexander en eps oro font se convirtió
en el primer periodista ruso
oficialmente investigado por noticias
falsas tras denunciar el ataque contra
un hospital materno infantil en mariupol
en medio de la guerra algunos
comunicadores decidieron rebelarse les
contamos las historias
volvemos con ustedes si tenemos las
noticias de ucrania en france 24
empezamos con la actualizaciones de la
situación la capital kiev es sigue
sacudida por explosiones pero las
fuerzas ucranianas lograron detener el
avance de los rusos y retomaron el
suburbio de macarí las autoridades de la
ciudad de gerson en el sur del país
denunciaron estar al borde del desastre
humanitario debido a la escasez de
alimentos y productos básicos y ciudades
como mariupol y elvis resistiera
hoy uno de los convoyes humanitarios ha
sido capturado por los ocupantes rusos
cerca de manos ya en la ruta acordada y
las manos
los rescatistas de los servicios de
emergencia y los conductores de
autobuses han sido capturados estamos
haciendo todo lo posible para liberar a
nuestro pueblo y desbloquear el
movimiento de la ayuda humanitaria antes
el secretario general de naciones unidas
antonio guterres calificó la invasión
rusa como una guerra absurda la onu
advirtió que las repercusiones amenazan
con convertirse en una crisis global de
hambre
y
esta guerra no se puede ganar tarde o
temprano tendrá que pasar del campo de
batalla a la mesa de paz y eso es
inevitable la única pregunta es cuántas
vidas más deben perderse cuántas bombas
más deben caer cuántas mariupol se deben
ser destruidas
cuántos ucranianos y rusos más deben
morir antes de que todo el mundo se dé
cuenta de que esta guerra no tiene
ganadores sino sólo perdedores winners
con ilusiones
la continuación de la guerra en ucrania
es moralmente inaceptable políticamente
indefendible y militarmente up surf en
símbolo militar lee jones en seco
previamente hablamos con roberto garcía
ex canciller y ex embajador de argentina
ante las naciones unidas a quien nos
habló sobre una posible crisis mundial
de hambre a raíz de la guerra rusa en
ucrania
yo tengo una inversión que él tiene es
grave los precios de los commodities
están subiendo y está claro que algunos
de viso commodities santana están casi
en el doble de su valor normal que decir
en el campo energético sin embargo
escribió que yo otros proveedores de
alimentos como puede ser el caso de
argentina sus producciones están
intactas y no creo que lleguemos a ese
punto tengo la esperanza que entreno y
me actúe con razonabilidad y
responsabilidad cese el ataque y permita
que esta situación lamentable y los
últimos 27 de ellas terminen y empezamos
y podamos empezar a reconstruir y tratar
de controlar los efectos porque las
crisis humanitarias y las crisis de
alimentación que acaba de decir podrían
ser graves en la medida que se extiende
el conflicto en el tiempo más de 3,5
millones de ucranianos han tenido que
abandonar sus hogares los países vecinos
los reciben por miles con problemas de
salud física y mental la organización
mundial de la salud pidió asistencia
urgente
la cifra de refugiados ucranianos
aumenta vertiginosamente más de 35
millones han huido de la guerra que los
afecta desde lo físico hasta lo
psicológico de las más de 2 millones de
personas refugiadas en polonia alrededor
de medio millón sufre de trastornos de
salud mental y 30.000 presentan
problemas graves según acnur needs of te
refugies las necesidades de los
refugiados son muchas principalmente
problemas de salud al llegar de ucrania
lo que estamos viendo en los centros de
recepción es fiebre diarrea hipotermia
infecciones del tracto respiratorio
superior paro cardíaco angustia mental y
emocional and stress según naciones
unidas una de cada cinco personas se han
visto obligadas a abandonar ucrania más
de 540.000 se han ido a rumanía
aproximadamente 320 mil a hungría más de
250.000 a eslovaquia y rusia y unas
4.300 a belarús otro país frontera que
se ha visto afectado es moldavia que ya
venía con dificultades luego de dos años
de pandemia de kobe 19 la oms se pidió
asistencia urgente
the first bank primero y necesidad de un
apoyo psicosocial porque la gente ha
estado sufriendo mucho los niños son
alejados de sus familias así que hay un
tremendo estrés de salud mental segundo
hay que atender las enfermedades
crónicas con personas con hipertensión
arterial enfermedades cardiovasculares o
diabetes tercero las enfermedades
transmisibles en primer lugar el kobe 19
más de 365.000 personas han llegado a
moldavia de las cuales según el ministro
de salud del país 100.000 continúan en
el territorio la mitad son niños y los
demás son mujeres y ancianos
la infusión desató una ola de
solidaridad desde españa toneladas de
ayuda han sido distribuidas por cientos
de voluntarios y cada furgoneta que
llega a la frontera entre polonia y
ucrania con comida o material sanitario
vuelve a españa repleta de refugiados
y aunque vive a miles de kilómetros de
su natal ucrania la vida de natasha
también cambió de golpe el 24 de febrero
las ponemos cajas de medicina rosa lo
que era una empresa de venta de
productos de belleza y demostraciones de
cocina se ha convertido en un centro de
acopio de ayuda para los afectados por
la guerra este es una cocina o sea todo
esto ahora mismo es son medicamentos que
luego nosotros lo que vamos a hacer es
comprar las neveras para poder mandar no
también en frío y que llegue bien en
hasta ucrania y en nuestras manos en lo
que tenemos algo ahora mismo pues eso es
lo que tenemos que hacer es ayudar y si
hoy por ejemplo no hago una limpieza
facial y no cobro dinero
o sea ellos tienen menos ellos han
quedado sin casas
uno de los muchos voluntarios que
reciben y organizan lo que va llegando
es nahuel la pareja de natasha un
argentino residente en madrid dueño de
una inmobiliaria que acaba de volver de
polonia de traer a varios refugiados
ucranianos nosotros al final no fuimos
de nuestro país por decisión propia y
todo hemos perdido es esencia cuando te
vas de tu país y ver que eso es al final
se lo arrebatan y una decisión que
imaginamos que en nuestro dolor todavía
es mucho más grande el derecho perfecto
esta semana es jose el que emprende la
misma travesía que hizo nahuel este
texto por donde lo recoges a la gente si
seis mujeres y niños volverán con este
maestro de pedagogía que deja de lado su
trabajo y a su familia durante unos días
es una suerte poder hacerlo yo voy muy
contento de poder hacerlo ahora no me
supone un esfuerzo el máximo esfuerzo ha
sido que tengo un niño de 3 años alonso
que lo voy a dejar
de una semana pero creo que cuando él
sea mayor lo entenderá mientras josé
recorre kilómetros la actividad en el
local de natasha no cesa comienza una
nueva operación logística para enviar
más ayuda a ucrania
los periodistas rusos comienzan a
enfrentar investigaciones del gobierno
peligran quienes no cumplen con la ley
que prohíbe hablar contra el ejército o
la operación especial en ucrania como le
llama a la guerra el presidente putin
acusado de difundir información falsa
por informar la realidad de la guerra
rusa en ucrania el periodista alexander
next oro podría enfrentar una pena de
hasta 15 años de cárcel luego de que la
justicia rusa abriera una investigación
en su contra las autoridades rusas dicen
desconocer su paradero según la
investigación a pesar de la negación
oficial de tesoro público
deliberadamente información falsa en sus
páginas públicas en instagram y youtube
ningún periodista en medio de
comunicación puede publicar contenidos
que usen la palabra guerra o que vayan
en contra de la versión rusa de lo que
sucede en ucrania luego de que el
parlamento ruso probará a principios de
marzo una ley contra la prensa el deneb
sarov es el primer caso iniciado desde
la promulgación de la ley entretanto de
este martes una corresponsal en europa
de la cadena oficialista rusa canal 1
renunció a su trabajo por estar en
desacuerdo con la línea editorial
que está fuera de toda duda a seguir así
su pacto está fuera de toda duda lo que
amara esto una operación pacífica
subsidiaria es una guerra y hay que
llamarla así sin dudarlo se la viaja el
14 de marzo un empleada de ese mismo
canal irrumpió en el estudio con una
pancarta que decía no a la guerra paren
la guerra no crean en propagandas la
mujer desapareció varias horas y le
impusieron una multa de 280 dólares bajo
el argumento de esa ley el kremlin abrió
una investigación penal contra verónica
veloz cerco busca ya bloguera y editora
rusa que vive en francia por difundir
información que consideran falsa de que
las fuerzas armadas rusas estaban
atacando a civiles ucranianos incluidos
niños y moscú decidió bloquear la
transmisión canal de televisión euronews
que se transmitía en ruso desde hace 20
años
esto es france24
[Música]